the worst of Mexico's COBIT 19 contagion
could be only days away
Mexico's deputy Health Minister warns
the National Health System could soon be
under the greatest pressure from the
virus
Boyka demos dad today we want to start
phase 3 of the pandemic remembering that
we are in the phase of rapid ascent
where a large number of cases of
infections and hospitalizations will
accumulate and we must continue to
maintain social distancing so that these
are minimized as much as possible for
Mexican health officials phase 3 refers
to the point where the virus will spread
the fastest hitting its peak in the
first half of May the announcement also
coincides with another major public
policy change the passage of a new
amnesty law which will oversee the
release of thousands of low-level
offenders from Mexican prisons but this
will allow us to release people from
prison who have not committed serious
crimes those who are sick or elderly
this will allow us to carry out a
humanitarian gesture human rights
organizations have warned that Mexico's
overcrowded prisons are a ticking time
bomb for contagion of coronavirus those
familiar with the legislation however
say that while the new law is an
important milestone in social justice it
will take months to implement meaning
the impact on kovat 19 containment will
likely be minimal I think this is an
important law that we've needed for a
long time because of all the injustice
that occurs but one thing should be
clear this law will not contribute to
the depressurization of the penitentiary
system in the context of covert 19 but
it could help in the future and for
future pandemics also bracing for the
worst of the virus or tens of thousands
of migrants among them asylum seekers
stuck in Mexico under tough new rules
imposed by the Trump administration
governors across the on Monday US
president Donald Trump tweeted that he
would be temporarily suspending
immigration to the United States Mexican
officials say they don't expect this
latest executive order by the White
House to have much impact on existing
Cobin 19 containment policy which
already restricts migration and includes
a partial closure of the us-mexico
border monrell rapido al jazeera Mexico
City